26 cargos por delitos de odio y uso de
armas de fuego este es el número de
acusaciones que enfrenta a peyton games
from el joven de 18 años que perpetró la
masacre de búfalo el departamento de
justicia estadounidense imputó
formalmente al joven calificado de
supremacista este miércoles el fiscal
general de eeuu de visita en el lugar
del tiroteo dio a conocer la noticia
de after en la declaración jurada en
apoyo de la denuncia cita al acusado
afirmando que su objetivo era matar
tantos negros como fuera posible la
declaración jurada describe como el
acusado se preparó durante meses para
llevar a cabo este ataque
algunas de estas imputaciones pueden ser
condenadas con la pena máxima
primero por supuesto tiene que haber una
acusación después de la acusación se
seguirán los procedimientos
reglamentarios y se consultará a las
familias ya los supervivientes las
denuncias a gendron consisten en diez
cargos por cometer un crimen de odio con
resultado de muerte tres cargos por
intento de asesinato diez cargos por
usar un arma de fuego para cometer un
asesinato durante y en relación con un
delito de violencia y tres cargos de uso
y descarga de un arma de fuego durante
un delito de violencia el pasado 14 de
mayo peyton gran dron viajó hasta el
supermercado tops de la localidad de
buffalo con un casco militar una cámara
y fuertemente armado con un equipamiento
táctico asesinó a 10 personas
afroamericanas jenson fue sometido a
exámenes psiquiátricos al manifestar una
conducta suicida pero el personal que lo
trató consideró que no suponía ningún
peligro a la sociedad el tiroteo de
búfalo se sumó a una serie de hechos
mortales que dejaron decenas de
fallecidos como la matanza y duval de
texas que avivaron el debate sobre el
porte y control de armas en el país